ouais
seconde signifie le changement
d'ateliers pour les collégiens sous
forme de speed dating avec une rotation
toutes les 20 minutes les élèves
découvrent trois métiers différents
l'objectif en danse et 20 minutes assez
des échanges sur les parcours de métiers
les formations pour accéder à ces
métiers et surtout les activités
quotidiennes de ses métiers gris pour
que les élèves pourrait se poser des
questions les élèves de 4e commencent
leurs réflexions sur leur orientation
ils sont eux aussi présents durant cette
matinée accompagné des troisièmes nous
explique nous faire une parle un peu de
ce qui se passe dans cette entreprise ça
nous permet de savoir qu en savoir plus
sur certains métiers métiers de service
de l'industrie ou encore du btp les
professionnels expliquent leur parcours
aux élèves et leur font découvrir de
nouveaux secteurs dans les métiers du
transport il ya du travail a pas de
chômage
c'est vraiment des secteurs d'activité
d'avenir avec des métiers qui évolue
énormément avec des technologies des
logiciels qui évoluent sur place
également une école de commerce qui
ouvre en octobre 2019 sur le territoire
l'occasion pour les élèves de découvrir
les formations proposées
quand on demande aux jeunes qu est-ce
que quelqu'un comme métier dans la
sphère sportive
on nous parle de professeur de sport on
nous parle de coach sportive ont été
métier très opérationnelle sans pour
autant savoir qu' il ya tout un
écosystème qui tourne autour du sport
business donc sur des métiers liés au
secteur de la communication du marketing
du management on a une réelle charge de
travail est vraiment matière à
renseigner les gens sur tous ces métiers
là une connaissance sur les métiers des
réponses à leurs questions qui
permettront aux collégiens de faire pour
le mois de mai leur demande
d'affectation